where's the oven because that one's
gonna be something which you my dear
friend a little bit big
oh come on come on hey where you know
I've major spices yeah I've wiped your
nose a POJO garlic of chopped onions
well you know you've got to give the
whole desert experience the hairs
display it oh come on that's ground
you've got to dig up a bit
we need about three feet deep three feet
wide
yeah and three feet right long this is
square pit you're spoiled
I am hey you know what better way to get
someone as great as chef as you to do
this for us you just need to bid your
back a little more like space and you
might need to come around this way
that's it I'm imagining that this is a
certain person's face that bit more and
then we are done last time I dug this
deep was in the second [ __ ] of
Britain its goodness have you heard of
skating this no I haven't yeah yeah we
used to holiday there fish and chips
grunting dinner so what were you digging
for their house playing sand castles ah
that's that's the sound out of you just
Buffy that's perfect
now we're surrounding the rap goat with
hot coals and bearing in sand pit
cooking with developed by the desert
nomads who wanted to travel light
without cooking utensils
like on this perfect now it's gonna be
in there for say about two hours we pull
it out and hope for the best really I
think I deserve a beer I think I do do
you deserve [ __ ] Oh God
I taught you everything okay
bozos dinner guests aren't slumming out
here his sermons have laid on some home
comforts in the dunes
I feel like bloody Captain Caveman that
looks fantastic
notice it's just a red mm-hmm we need to
open it up a bit nice
what got the knife and forks there we
are
please use my fingers thank you
summoners please those out out delicious
what a wonderful wife cooking goat hmm
was nice as the getting all the spices
without being you know chili hot miss
wet with the bread ran the outside which
I didn't think would be tasty but the
bread absorbs the juices it takes the
juices in here and it's sort of pregnat
it with the spices so there's one thing
I've learned tonight this has been in
the desert is sticking to tradition
tradition the tradition well done
you